hello everybody and welcome to awesome
comics your one-stop shop for everything
comic book entertainment I am your host
Walter Benes yakin today it's a viewers
request we're talking about our favorite
DC animated movies I cannot wait to get
into this but first once again I want to
thank you guys for commenting and
suggesting what you guys want us to talk
about keep doing that please we will do
as much as we can of what you guys
suggest remember to up like this video
by the way I don't say that enough let's
get some up likes going okay go ahead
and like this video if you like the
content okay um I want to make one
announcement before we get started next
week we're gonna be reviewing Captain
America Civil War and we're gonna have
two very special guests on the show mr.
Doug Walker and mr. waadt Rob Walker you
guys excited about that yes we're gonna
have the Walker brothers on set team Rob
Team Rob team Doug it's gonna be great
they're gonna be talking with Civil War
with us next week so make sure you come
back next week for that okay but this
week DC animated movies there's a lot of
really really good ones oh yeah oh yes
we are
and here to talk about it today miss
ayan away and mr. Brian booted up okay
everybody let's just jump right into
this okay I Anna your first what is your
favorite DC animated movie it's such
it's such a really really good animated
film not even just for its time but
overall it was considered one of the
best superhero if not just Batman at
least movies until recently I was sure
the score is phenomenal I was I had that
in my nose - Shirley Walker passed away
I think in like 2000 or something but
she's like an unsung hero of the
animated series and of this movie is
great yeah just the main like even just
the title theme is just really good I
was reading somewhere that it's people's
names backwards are the words that
they're seen yeah really it's just the
names backwards which i think is really
really
and the animated style is really really
really good I mean if you're watching a
lot of the the more recent stuff
obviously it's older animation style
kind of drawn animation right it's gonna
charm to it yeah it's it's really good
old school Batman for me oh yeah
it's I mean it's animated series style
that takes place in the animated series
universe and it's it's I love the
animation styles yeah Bruce Timm was all
over that with that yes voice actors in
it are phenomenal
we got Mark Hamill as the Joker and if
you're looking forward to killing joke
maybe if you haven't seen it I know a
lot of you have seen it right but if you
haven't Mark Hamill was saying that this
is where he really figured out his Joker
voice and laugh and like this is like
this specific one in this movie is is
the one that we hear now yeah he's great
yeah I mean he's so devious in this
movie I mean like Mark Hamill he's just
like so special as the Joker I know I
mean I love Heath Ledger I love Jack
Nicholson I'm sure I'm just like before
Heath Ledger so this was really taking
it to stuff in a different you know
you're out of his voice which was kind
of cool you're absolutely right but I
mean I think a lot of people just go
automatically to live-action versions of
the Joker but like Hamill is a joker is
just so awesome yeah my favorite you're
no special or ever be Mark Hamill's like
it doesn't you know Nicholson or Heath
Ledger they don't beat Mark Hamill is
over for me he were the best yeah you
know you always talk about you know -
speaking of Killing Joke
Baxter around the Joker we kind of get a
little bit of the back story on this guy
we see what he's up to you before the
bleach baths right exactly how he draws
the I love that I love that little touch
Bruce sees that picture and we
definitely see some of them Batman's
detective nurse in this - this is a
really good old-school detective
background
I did really like the first scene like
her the first time out is Batman just
the ski mask ensure conventions I
thought that was a really awesome is
very reminiscent of year one in year 2
which is a lot of this was based on and
I thought it was good but overall like
for some reason I just rewatched it I
could not get into the movie
I was it's slower pace kinda bored and
I'm very just some of the other ones
we're gonna be talking about today it's
definitely a slower paced movie but I
don't think that makes it a bad movie
anything was bad specifically for an
animated film but in superhero film in
general it really like packs a lot of
complicated like like character driven
story of it definitely a lot we really
see Bruce's struggle with keeping his
promise to his parents and then also
wanting to actually find happiness in
life and a lot of people think you know
like Bruce kind of has like this
vengeance idea this Vendetta but we kind
of see in this that it's really it's
it's not such a cool villain yeah good
boy I rewatched it even just on my
laptop and my crappy little laptop
speakers it's still like chilly he's
legit scary like when you see him show
up with the smoke and stuff at the
beginning just all men's I really the
graveyard he was scary yeah I really
like the phantasm but with the reveal of
who would actually ok spoiler is if you
haven't seen it ok its Andrea Beaumont
it was like Bruce's first love basically
they was going to marry
I love the whole backstory stuff with
them yeah they're in him I mean I think
that's great I think which was really
cool and for for a film after the
success of the animated series and
everything they really wanted to be able
to like do like a story-driven thing but
also be able to touch on things with
death with blood and we see this and so
hey if Killing Joke is gonna be hard I'm
never able to get this much story out of
a PG I know those are the times - this
came out also it wasn't originally
supposed to come out no theatrical
release is supposed to be
direct-to-video and that was one of the
reasons it was a flop but it wasn't a
flop there was there wasn't enough
critics that went to see it on time
right they came out with like Saturday
reviews which no one reads really yeah
but at before it's time it should have
been able to do better but it was a
last-minute decision to do with the at
record release I agree I mean in this we
you know we talked about the flashbacks
that we get to see Batman put on his cow
for the very first time and you don't
even see his face you just see his eyes
and arrow and how Alfred is terrified oh
so cool so the robotics work well a lot
of good points I like the movie but for
overall I was just kind of bored I don't
understand why your document it was a
fully formed story I thought like the
slow parts were kept my attention even
if it was slow like it was building
story right there's a lot of character
interaction that made sense with Bruce I
love Bruce at the his parents grave at
the big headstone and everything I think
all that's cool I like Andre a boma a -
I mean like she's not a fantastic
character I don't think but I think
she's well-rounded enough where I would
believe Bruce falling for this kind of
girl and that he would give it all up to
be happy and then it turns out to be
another tragic thing in this past I
pushes him towards being Batman yeah so
that's really cool stuff I thought it
was just really weird for me like and
it's weird because I love the animated
series so much yeah and to me it's like
this was a good it was a good movie but
their animated series episodes that I
liked even better oh no III agree with
that better as a story and sure 20
minutes there are a lot of animated
series episodes of my opinion too that
are better than this movie but this
movie is great it's a good movie I just
I just wasn't as engrossed as it would
be on any like half of the show or have
the episode I think there's like a
handful I don't know maybe like a
handful of episodes that are better than
this but that's for another time do you
want to see us review Batman animated
series talk about a favorite episodes
because I would love to if that's what
you want to see even leave it in the
comments we would love to talk about
Batman series my favorite maybe my
favorite TV show period so leave
comments about that okay there's more
stuff to talk about with the guy move on
unfortunately
okay we'll go on to mine here mine is
Batman Beyond return of the Joker
this is the best Batman Beyond story and
it is a great way to end the main run of
this show but it also bookends Batman
the Animated Series this is all canon
folks this is a canon of the DCAU so we
get to see like the last days of the
Joker in this we get to see like what
happened at Tim Drake is just
mind-blowing you know
it's brutal it is demented and it is
great so yeah I wanted to talk about
just the emotion in this I loved Terry
McGinnis I know a lot of people are sort
of so-so on Terry I don't know why he's
a fantastic I love Terry McGinnis I like
him so much because he is so different
from Batman he is such a completely
different character mentions in the
movie yeah so good he's like I'm not the
same man right where are you I'm not
like your other kids and right he was a
bad kid like I love all that stuff so
Terry is a great main character for this
when Joker comes back oh my god Mark
Hamill did a little bit of a darker
Joker in this I think that this is a
little bit of a different direction for
him to take on it because he's a little
bit older and he has a little bit of a
deeper voice you know and a lot of that
stuff so what do you guys think of of
Hamill's performance as a Joker and
Bambi an eternal Joker I liked it was
amazing everything he expanded
everything on the original to a tee he
was great and then he added some a
little bit new nuances to the Joker and
it's just top-notch like you cannot beat
mark Hamill's joke you can't you
definitely can there's you know when he
reappears to Bruce you know when Bruce
season for the first time old man Bruce
Wayne sees this Joker were like reappear
right in front of them and it's it's
just like you could see in his eyes like
the shock and all he tells teri like no
you're done you you can't go up against
this guy because of how awful he is but
he's being so Bruce Wayne in this he's
being very stern about it he's very
unapologetic you know stupid kid you
don't know what you want none of you
ever did that's a great line and I think
their relationship makes this thing and
the show to work very well
the old man Bruce Wayne is such a cool
like different take on the character -
I'd love to see a live-action Bambi on
movie eventually just get Kevin awesome
please do that eventually I want to see
I want to see something like that I
think maybe one of the best scenes
period in the DCAU is is this scene when
the Joker shows like the home movies of
how he tortured Robin and got out of him
who Bruce was and all the secrets and
everything so
Oly heavy and there's the line I'll just
read it
behind all the strum and batarangs
you're just a little boy in a place to
crying for mommy and daddy it would be
funny if it weren't so pathetic what the
heck I laugh anyway that's great stuff
great line from Mark Hamill's Joker and
then Bruce basically goes crazy on them
after that it's it's the mental hold
that Joker has on Batman's how Joker and
Harley are able to like manipulate
exactly the right people to get to him
the emotional tone of that whole movie I
think was best like portrayed or
whatever in that flashback scene I mean
later with the you know final battle or
whatever like nothing beats that
flashback scene in the emotional tone
yeah the overall craziness of it I think
it was it was that was the best part of
the entire movie yeah I love that
absolutely loved it I think it's it's
the best DC animated like universe movie
like it's frickin fantastic and it ties
in to Batman Beyond and Batman the
original animated series so well so
check this one out if you haven't it is
fantastic and we're gonna go on to mr.
Porter's pick whether you're very hard
because Batman Beyond return of the
Joker was like my favorite up until this
movie and then just thinking about two
of them it's like how do I pick but for
me ultimately it's gonna be Batman under
the Red Hood it's great I love that
story so much and one of the reasons why
I love it just generally was because it
doesn't have Kevin Conroy and Mark
Hamill and all them like they nobody can
touch them nobody can be better than and
they will always be the best
but for bruce greenwood yeah and joe
dimaggio and jensen ackles John DiMaggio
the New York Yankees John DiMaggio like
that Joker was an awesome take on the
Joker but it still felt so much like the
joke very different yeah sort of darker
yeah I'm just a little bit more
no-nonsense but I think a little bit
like more unhinged
maybe that's definitely and I just loved
his voice I loved his laugh and then
bruce greenwood is definitely my number
two he's a really good man he sounds
great he's way better than
what's the new one they got out now he's
an O'Malley Jason O'Mara O'Mara right I
like I'm Way better than that but
because this movie holds its own so much
with this new voice cast is a big reason
why I like it so much because it
toe-to-toe with anything Hamill and
Conroy and I think that's great Jensen
Ackles is awesome as the Red Hood the
bred hood is such an awesome character
yeah Jason Todd you got from 1980s death
in the family how brutal that was the
900 number where the fans got to choose
whether he lived and died we killed him
and it was it didn't kill 20 years I
mean it was so good Judd Winick wrote
the movie he got Batman under the hood
the original graphic novel and it's just
so good it's an awesome story for the
continuation of Jason Todd's character
and how different he is from any other
Robin we had and what happens like just
Bruce says that he picked him up because
he was so different from dick and he
wanted to save him he wanted to say but
he could see what type of path that
would go down and I think this is the
culmination of that path but even worse
because of Batman's influence now he's I
mean he's so much danger he's dangerous
he's a murderer and he takes those
skills that he learned from Batman and
uses it for evil and it's and it's
awesome and it's an awesome what if like
what if Batman went bad Red Hood right
it works so well and and it goes back to
my favorite the emotional scene of this
whole movie was the end when he's got
the Joker and he's got the gun on Batman
he's like why why is he still alive
right all the you know people are
tormented like the friends he's crippled
nice shout out to Bette Barbara Gordon
yeah that whole scene emotionally was
awesome yeah and he's like I he had
taken you away from me there was nothing
I could have done that like I would have
done this now you know kill him or
whatever like Oh such a good thing he's
like I've been to Batman is like it'd be
too damned easy to go down that route
yeah and he's like I'm not talking about
killing penguin or dent like just him
and there's so much emotion I loved
Batman and just he couldn't he even
today there's that fight with those guys
dressed up and whatever I'm not sure
those guys are yeah before first
metaphor and like and Jason saves Batman
yeah so you could say he still really
cares about it and it's just such an
emotionally complex character and just
how the Lazarus Pit messed with his mind
it's like what no no no you didn't
really affect him that much or was this
the end like to ask that question if you
look at it from a like from a psychology
standpoint like he was a kid and then he
dies and then he comes back and he has
none of those formative years to to
actually become an adult and so he
becomes an adult with the mindset of a
child who is incredibly deadly what'd
you guys think of the the flashbacks
with showing young Jason Todd with Bruce
and stuff I really like specifically the
alley scene where like we see him with
the car right and then we see him
present day I specifically love the
visual of like that part in the alley
yeah I love the cutbacks and like how he
kind of narrates his time with Jason and
what he saw and all that stuff like oh I
was so good it was one of the best ways
to do flashbacks that were ever yeah the
final flashback scene where he get heat
the first time he's in the Robin costume
and he laughs you know come on old man
there's some bad guys we got a you know
take or whatever and he's like this is
the greatest day of my life seriously
hurts misty every single time and how
many times I watch it I will it it is
right in the heartstrings
it's by far my most favorite although
Killing Joke we'll see but where do you
want to see us do a whole episode of
Killing Joke we're probably gonna do it
anyway so leave a comment
hey guys it's Heather I'm here at
amazing fantasy books and comics in
Crown Point Indiana and we're gonna go
ask some people with their favorite DC
animated movie is so let's go
this is possibly the creepiest piece of
memorabilia I have ever seen I don't
know why you'd want to make a mask of
the Joker's literal rotting flesh but
apparently you can have it not creepy at
all alright I'm here with Mark who is
also apparently a real Ghostbuster can
we talk about the proton pack for a
second first here tell me a little bit
about it oh well it's just this one is
based off of the end of the movie it's a
stun pack so it's made out of
lightweight eda foam it's roughly about
ten pounds it's got the static lights
well looks fantastic but we have another
important question for you what is your
favorite DC animated movie I have to say
new frontier big fan of Darwin cooks the
storyline itself is just it's amazing to
see what could have happened if it the
comics code didn't implode the industry
the artwork excited it's just it's
beautiful and you got to admit when
Batman walks up to Martian Manhunter and
says I have spent you know $80,000 on a
piece of meteor sliver for you I just
need a penny for a book of matches to
stop you you got to give it up so have
you seen the trailer at all for killing
Joe I have are you excited or it's been
waiting forever you know Mark Hamill and
Kevin Conroy doing an r-rated Batman
movie how can you not be excited they
are Batman and Joker so do you think
it's a good thing that it has an R
rating to it of course it is it's about
time that was the whole purpose of DC
doing the animated features
direct-to-video was so that they could
do R rated pg-13 movies it's just taken
him a long time to get to that point now
if they could stuff up I go from Batman
to likes a green lantern with blackest
night or even Kingdom Come that would be
awesome
so if you come check us out on may 7th
is Free Comic Book Day which everyone
knows it's gonna be huge random bunch of
cosplayers we're gonna have giveaways
every year it gets bigger and bigger
last year we had a line out the door
that went three of three storefronts
down so hoping this year will be even
bigger personally my favorite DC
animated movie is under the Red Hood it
has a fantastic story great characters
and I love the animation style so I
really hope at least one of you fix it
this has been Heather at amazing fantasy
books and comics in Crown Point Indiana
back to you guys in the studio
Thanks
okay right now we're gonna go into our
picks of the week and they tie into our
individual movies let's go with Ayanna
first so mine I'm going into the digital
realm this week
do you read comic books physically or do
you get them on your apps let me know
I'm interested to hear what your
favorite way is my pick is Batman
adventures which is based off the
animated series as well and issue number
seven is phantasm strikes which ties
into my movie definitely and bonus we
get a little Batgirl action back : I
love a little bad girl action I'll have
a lot of acryl action uh I really I
really super like that we get some
phantasm in there again and also we get
it to see a little bit of Batman and
Batgirl at the end that's kind of the
trust that Batman has to have in Batgirl
because he's trained Robins and
everything for a while and he sort of
doesn't really know Barbara's background
and sort of has to have a lot of faith
in her as a sidekick and it's really I
really like their relationship in this
issue specifically it's a good issue
check it out and actually the whole
Batman adventures series is really fun
there's some good Robin bits in there as
well so you should check that out cool
stuff reporter what did you pick I
picked Batman hush specifically because
towards the end of the book we see Jason
Todd as Robin come back from the dead
this is this is the first appearance of
chasing Todd back from the dead
it was retconned later by Judd Winick
and visually it is awesome Jim Lee the
drawing on this is perfect and it's an
awesome story and it's a great awesome
kind of tie in towards the how this
story ends the book itself is amazing
you need to pick it up and just not even
just for Red Hood this whole book is is
one of the best Batman stories ever so
Batman hush pick it up awesome it is a
great book I can attest that okay we're
for return of the Joker I wanted to pick
something a little bit different so I
didn't go with the Bambi on book I
actually went with Brian Azzarello
Joker book from a few years back this is
got a lot of buzz when it came out it
kind of has a little bit of a Heath
Ledger vibe to him like Joker has like
the scars on the sides of his cheeks and
stuff like that liebherr Maggio I think
is how you pronounce his last name he
does some really good art in here just
see a little bit right there it's good
really like down and dirty kind of kind
of stuff he also switches to like more
realistic type of sort of almost
watercolor painting type stuff not not
to the point of Alex Ross but still some
some really good realistic type art in
here so it's a really good look inside
of the Joker so it kinda ties him to
return of the Joker where you could see
his thought process a little bit better
but okay those are our picks of the week
our comic book picks of the week because
those are comic books and we just talked
about them and you saw us talk about
them so thanks a lot we really
appreciate it okay next week folks we're
gonna be talking about Captain America
Civil War I can't wait so excited we're
gonna have Doug and Rob Walker here the
Walker brothers will join us there
sibling rivalry will combine with
awesome comics to give you a really
amazing review of a great movie I'm sure
it's gonna be I'm really excited for it
okay so for you guys where can we find
in the social medias you can find me on
Facebook Twitter Instagram and that'll
be right here for you Oh convenient oh
she's always there for you Oh a
supporter facebook.com slash awesome
Porter just talk about some stuff from
the show general musings and stuff so
look me up alright I am on twitter at
awesome underscore Walter I put up
basically whatever I want I try to put
up some stuff about you know like news
for animated movies and stuff I've been
talking about The Killing Joke on there
a lot so if you're interested in my
thoughts on that go ahead and check that
out until we talked about on the show so
until next time for these two lovely
people here I am Walter Bernays II AK
and we will see you next week on the
next page
you